Matt Miller bleacher report NFL draft
expert and has been doing so for a
decade or so good to have you back Matt
how are you I'm doing well Dan it's good
to be back home with you guys as well I
explained this Joe Cena Anderson had
something that maybe somebody's going up
to get the number two pick with the
Washington Redskins factor I mean is
there something here
I'm sure someone has tried but that
doesn't mean it's gonna happen and I
think with chase young I almost feel
like this happens every year usually
with an Ohio State defense event I just
happen to make enjoy Bosa to wear by
late April were like oh we're over this
guy he's been great for three years I
don't want to hear about it anymore like
chase Young is the best player in the
trap no disrespect to Joe Barrow
shishah was the best player in the draft
he should be a 10 or 12 sack player
right away you're gonna have an amazing
impact that's not the kind of guy you
trade away from especially when I do
think he doesn't need so I'm I'm sure
Joe seam is right I'm sure someone did
offer a package of picks that doesn't
mean Washington has to take that package
of picks as you were saying before I
think it's more likely the trade Trent
Williams whether that's to the the
Browns the Buccaneers the Broncos
someone in that 10 to 15 pick range and
then they you know they double down and
get an offensive tackle somewhere in the
you know middle of the first round and I
don't know who needs that tackle more is
it is it Denver is it Cleveland or is it
Tim I mean Tampa's offensive line is not
good at all but if you were gonna place
Trent Williams where would you place him
well I'm sure Williams I want to go to
Tampa I'm gonna play with Tom Brady and
Rob Gronkowski and have fun down there
at the adult establishments that they
have in Tampa Bay I don't go to
Cleveland and Dylan Baker Mayfield and
and you know all the personalities on
that team Denver would be okay but like
you're not beating Pat mahomes in the
Chiefs so if you go to Denver you see at
best you're a wild card team first long
as you know he's 32 for the rest of your
career
you're a wild card team so if I'm sure
William but I think he's his own agent
so he should be talking to Kyle Smith
and the Redskins today saying hey I want
to go to Tampa that's where I want to
end up because other than that I mean
you know the Jets even a lot of the
other teams that need offensive tackles
it might be willing to trade they're
just they're not good teams and you have
the pot
ability of going to Tampa which I heard
this morning that they almost dealt for
him a couple weeks ago they almost
traded OJ Howard for Trent Williams so I
think there's already a framework there
that hopefully something like that does
get done who will make a trade tomorrow
in the first round well I think a lot of
people I think we're asking a lot of
trades this year because these GM's have
been sitting at home trying to avoid
their wives and kids with nothing to do
but get on the phone with each other so
I think we'll see a lot of trades I
think we Panthers probably want to trade
back the Cardinals the Jaguars probably
want to trade back so that's three teams
in the top ten I think the Falcons would
like to come up to get CJ Henderson from
Florida
feels like the Broncos would like to
come up as well to get a wide receiver
like Jerry Judy from Alabama or CD lamb
from Oklahoma so I think we could see a
decent amount of action you know also
like we always see a little bit at the
end of the first round but the 49ers
don't have a pick in around two three or
four they're gonna want more picks the
Chiefs only have five selections in this
trap they're going to want more picks
Saints only have five picks so I think
we could even see those you know 24 to
32 we can see a lot of action there if
people try to get out when we're re
watching this draft in five years who's
the quarterback that we can't believe
was drafted in that spot if I said
burrow to a Herbert Jordan lover Jalen
Hertz I will take Jordan love just
because I feel like he does have the
best potential but potential such a
dirty word in evaluating because not
very many people realize it I'm sure
like everybody else I was watching the
2017 redraft last night you seem a
homeless Paul Burton and and there'd be
a lot of skepticism of what this guy is
going to be he went to the perfect
landing spot and for Jordan love it
would take a similar perfect landing
spot maybe that's the coax where he can
sit and learn from Phillip Rivers
somewhere where he's not going to be
forced into action right away maybe it's
Tampa where you can learn behind Tom
until he's ready to move on but I think
Jordan loves raw talent is really
intriguing not to the point that he
should be a top five pick maybe not even
a top 10 pick but I do think if there's
me one guy on the positive side if
there's one guy that surprises us it
would be Jordan love on the negative I
mean I feel really good to Justin
Hurwitz going to go number five overall
and I feel really good that he should
not go number five overall so he might
be
the mr. Ricky I just don't think he's
that good Dan I really don't I everyone
when they talk about Justin Herbert they
point to one game the Rose Bowl and then
it's like Oh buddy look how good he was
the Senior Bowl in the combine you're in
short there's no defense but man indeed
why don't other teams see it I think
because I don't have to draft a
quarterback or I'm gonna lose my job
like read reports not gonna fire me if
I'd miss out a quarterback you know I'm
gonna get bounced on Twitter that's all
it's gonna have to do there's so much
pressure from owners and fans and
especially you know if you're Miami you
haven't had a quarterback since Dan
Marino and you have to look at what drew
Brees does every year in New Orleans and
say we passed on that so now I think
there is just an incredible amount of
pressure it's why EJ Manuel goes in the
first round it's why you trade up for
Mitch Travis key it's you know this
position when any other get other gets
over evaluated
Justin Herbert at the end of the year
was not the second best quarterback in a
strap class but Thursday night he'll be
drafted at that spot so I think that's
where our teams miss and and mess up and
I hope I'm wrong I want every player
succeed but I just cannot sign off on
that guy being a top five pick what
about - I love to a man it you just feel
bad for him because the injuries I think
I think that's who Miami should drafts
but again if you know if he has
arthritis in his hip and can't play the
level they expect I don't get fired for
saying that's who they should draft
there are questions there he's had four
surgeries in two years know the hand
both ankles in the hip and even if you
say hey he's good for football activity
okay he is today April 22nd what's going
to happen October 5th
how is he going to look there he's not
stayed healthy for an entire season at
Alabama and so I think when you draft
him that's just something you might have
to deal with you might have to be aware
of the fact that we might not get this
guy for 16 games this might be a Ben
Roethlisberger situation we're shooting
really good ways on the field and when
he's not you need to have a pretty good
backup because it might not be our 17
games once we get to that level but I
think - it does everything you want
touch timing accuracy you know like the
the most important part of playing the
position can you throw the ball where
it's supposed to go to it does that
really really Willie does it
consistently from the pockets
on the move it's you know outside of the
injuries I think is everything you would
want well that's why I'm the Chargers
and he falls into my lap at six and I'm
moving into a new stadium and and we can
sit him for as long as we want with
Tyrod Taylor you know and I've had
people say this when it comes to the
draft you take risk you take chances Dan
Orlovsky said hey you take a check I
know what Justin Herbert is I'm not
quite sure what two is going to be don't
be afraid to be great don't be afraid to
roll the dice here if I'm the Chargers
and two is there and you and you really
feel like you want a quarterback I
consider that a godsend I do too and
it's not just from a business
perspective of you're moving into a new
stadium you need a face of the franchise
from a football perspective like you
said they are telling everyone who will
listen that they like Tyrod Taylor okay
let's hi rod play until you feel
comfortable with to it so he can
acclimate and you're really really
comfortable with the health but I do
think people forget to owners are
involved in the draft in a normal year
that owner is in the draft room with
everyone helping make these decisions
and eventually you have to sell tickets
to a being from Hawaii keep them over
there on the west coast in LA he's going
to be a superstar and you're also
getting I think he's the most marketable
most well-known player in this draft
Joe burrow is gonna be the first pick to
is the household name I get asked about
him more than any player in the draft so
I think it makes sense for the Chargers
not to mention how amazing is he gonna
look in those new you look like they're
Minnesota team two is meant to be a
charger that's great maybe they'll make
it and look faster Matt Miller bleacher
report NFL draft insider joining us he
right I'm gonna make you the GM and just
give me like a 10 or 15 second what you
would do you're the Bengals GM what do
you do at number one
Joe burrow without I've already handed
the card and it's that easy okay
the Redskins chase young again similar
is that easy this is a generational type
talent Detroit I would trade I would try
to trade out I think you could move back
to five or six and still get Jeff hakuta
the coroner from Ohio State
would you consider a quarterback
at 3:00 not upon the Lions they have too
much money wrapped up in Matthew
Stafford I think you have to you're
paying them thirty million dollars this
year I think you have to give it one
more year if it doesn't work make sure
you look at Trevor Lawrence trail ants
Justin fields in 2020 ones when you move
on if you have to in the New York Giants
so I would take Isaiah Simmons because I
know exactly what he is he's a
difference maker I compared him to Sean
Taylor like I've never seen anyone on
events like this they'll probably take
an offensive tackle because of dead
gentlemen but the the chance like Isaiah
Simmons is so much better at his
position then all these tackles aren't
there's there's not you know there's not
a Trent Williams and tyronn Smith
there's not an elite tackle Isaiah
sometimes there's an elite defensive
player Miami Dolphins I would take two
uh and and say you know what we we
missed on Drew Brees because we were a
little afraid to take a risk we're not
gonna make that same mistake again
the Chargers if two is not there so I
would take a tackle I would take Jedrek
wills the traitor Russell O king I would
take a tackle role of Tyrod Taylor and
then in the second round I would draft
Jalen Hertz he's probably going to be
there he fits what they want to do
offensively at 37 overall if I could
walk out of there with Jedrek wills and
Jalen Hertz I would feel very very good
about my first two picks and I was
wondering if let's say tua is available
for Carolina available for Jacksonville
available for the Raiders out of those
three teams who bites I I would say the
Jags just because Gardner mentioned you
have nothing invested in him like he got
kind of lucky last year that he was good
salaries unimportant and if you replace
him it's a discover today three pick we
didn't value him that much at the time
we now have a very inexpensive very good
quarterback room the Panthers have
invested in Teddy for a couple years and
with the Raiders I actually don't think
two is a great fit for John Gruden's
office so I can understand the allure
there you know John always wants to get
better at quarterback but I think of
those Jacksonville would be the best fit
for him I'll leave you with this write
the headline for Friday morning oh wow
that's tough I mean I think the headline
is going to be about the quarterbacks
falling in perverts going to go five and
then
where to it goes if he doesn't go six
you do the Patriots trade up to get him
do the Saints get their quarterback of
the future to the Packers get a
quarterback of the future so I think you
know when I stumble out of bed Friday
morning that's probably what I'll be
thinking about is how much the
quarterback landscape in the NFL changed
overnight
great stuff Matt and have fun tomorrow
we appreciate your time
yeah preciate you guys have a great one
that's Matt Miller bleacher report NFL
draft expert